TAMZIN TAYLOR: So
the next session
is about how to manage your CEO.
So let me ask you
how many people--
hands up if you're an
employee and not the CEO.
Excellent, so
hopefully, you'll be
able to take away some
tangible lessons and tips
that you can take to rein
those crazy people in.
Who can empathize
with this meme?
Hands up.
Yeah.
Knowing how to handle the
prioritization of what
to build in your product when
you have so many competing
opinions, stakeholders,
self-interest,
not to mention important
people like your CEO or CFO's
very strong views, maybe on
the type of color of green,
for example.
So how do you avoid
opinion-based product
prioritization?
Well, this was an
interest of mine,
so a few months ago, I
interviewed about 15 to 20
of our top developers.
I interviewed Google engineers,
Google product managers,
directors of growth.
And I tried to tease
out of them, how
did they approach this problem?
And you know what
struck me was there
were two key characteristics.
The first is that successful
developers rely on data
to make a call on what
to experiment on first
and what to build.
And the second really
important factor
was that they had imbued this
culture of data and sharing
of information throughout
their organization.
So to add color and
context of this discussion,
in a few minutes,
I'll be inviting
on stage both 1tap and 2017
app of the year winner Memrise
to share with us their
experiences on reigning
in their crazy CEOs.
I know one of them
is there laughing.
He's not that crazy.
So let's get started
with prioritization.
And just to note, the
models and suggestions
that we make here today are
just some of the best practices
that you can use.
So they're not the
only ones you can use,
but hopefully, you'll
be able to take away
some key nuggets of gold.
So just a few seconds
ago, many of you
had put up your hands to say
that prioritization was hard.
But it can be made
easier with data.
Thank you for reconfirming.
So over the last month, I've
worked with the 1tap team
to test out a model that
Google used internally
for deciding how to
prioritize what we build.
We use this model on
Allo, YouTube, Gmail,
and we actually have
an internal growth
team who gets a conduit out
to our different products.
So I harnessed that team,
and we worked with 1tap.
Now, again, this is not
the only way to do it.
Bear with me.
But if it gives you a
different perspective,
this is a good thing.
Now, before I introduce
John on stage,
let me just give you a brief
overview of this Google model.
So as you can see,
it's pretty simple.
It looks pretty simple.
It's made up of
four components--
the North Star metric,
user flows, a growth model,
and a spreadsheet.
Because, let's face
it, what database model
would be complete
without a spreadsheet?
Now, the model serves to help
you uncover opportunities,
and more importantly, it serves
as a common communication
tool for your whole company to
talk about growth, products,
and prioritization.
So to kick off and go deeper on
this, the first one I mentioned
was the North Star metric.
Now, listening to
Anthony [INAUDIBLE] talk
about behavioral
design, it struck me
that we were talking about
the same thing, which
is it's that key
engagement user metric.
Now, the way that we
define a North Star metric
is that it
encapsulates everything
that you do in your app, and
it encapsulates all the value
that you're providing to a user.
So as an example, if anyone here
is staying at Airbnb this week,
it would be nights booked.
For WhatsApp, it would
be messages sent.
So again, the purpose is
to create a shared goal
across all of your different
divisions in your company,
so they're all going
for the same goal.
The next element is
mapping the user flows.
Has anyone here mapped
their user flows?
A few of you, good, so this
might be familiar to you.
The way that we approach it is
that, essentially, we define
user flows as a visual
representation of your user
journeys throughout your app
across acquisition, engagement,
conversion, and retention.
And that flows from sources
of acquisition, critical user
journeys, you drill down on
some important aspects, perhaps
your engagement activities,
and your retention activities.
Now, I can see you
taking photos madly.
The next bit's going to
really mess it up, so
take your photo now.
Once you've mapped this out--
and I quite like
the color coding.
It helps me visualize it better.
The next thing you want to do
is mess it up with some lines.
So you stick in how
all of these components
relate to one another, the
idea being that this will then
show you where some
of the activities
are not supporting
the rest of the app
and help you identify
opportunities to improve.
Now, that's all
well and good, but I
mentioned this was all
about data, didn't I?
So what's missing here,
and which will really
rely on you having a very
robust analytics system,
is to put in the proportion
of users who are successfully
going from step A to
step B, which will then
allow you to see where the
weak points are in your flow.
For example, there
might be some issues
with return from
notifications and some issues
with notification permission.
You can draw a conclusion there.
So this mapping of
user flows really
helps everyone in
your business talk
about the product
in the same way
and understand how
their activities impact
the overall North Star metric.
Once you've worked out where
your area for improvement is--
I mentioned notifications was
something in this example--
then next step is to drill down
on what are the key levers that
will impact that metric.
So in the case of
notifications, for example,
we had average users opted in.
We had average number
of notifications
sent, and for example,
the click through rate
of those notifications.
This is not rocket science,
but just drawing it out
helps everyone to be clear
on what the potential levers
you have are.
Now, I mentioned
there's this need
to have a spreadsheet
in here somewhere.
So once you've mapped
out that subsection,
transfer it to a spreadsheet,
link it all up together,
and you can run
scenario analysis
to compare your
different competing ideas
to see which one will have the
biggest impact on your North
Star metric.
Now, to tell us more
about their experience--
because as I said,
the North Star metric
seems pretty simple,
but I think we
know there's a lot more complex
thinking that goes into it--
I'd like to welcome on
stage John Butterfield, head
of growth of 1Tap.
JON BUTTERFIELD: So one of the
things we did when we first
started making this product
is focusing on analytics,
and we track everything a
user does within the app.
And this is something that
we are really proud of,
but we'll see how that unraveled
while working with Tamzin.
So the first thing we did,
as Tamzin showed you earlier,
was we've created this user
flow, this thing up here.
This is about the
10th iteration of it.
The first one had thousands and
thousands of different things
in it, and it was
just a cluster thing.
I won't say the word.
And so we dumbed
it down to this.
And we actually worked
with the head of growth
at Google on this one as well.
And the thing he really
gave us as a key takeaway is
don't include everything from
the app, just the key moments
in the key journeys.
And the first thing
listed for us,
actually, was show that
we have some problems,
and it's at the end, that
weird mustardy colored bit,
where it's essentially
like an exit point.
The user journey doesn't
come all the way back around.
So this was the first useful
part of building this model.
So the next thing was about
the North Star metric.
And now this is
an interesting one
because, for us,
it's pretty simple.
So our mission as a
company, as you can see,
is to make being self-employed
easier than being employed.
And so if we want
to make this easier,
the best thing we can
do is, quite simple--
there we go-- is
collect transactions.
The more transactions
we collect for a user,
the more we can
provide value, and it's
all about providing that value.
So transactions per user is
a really easy one for us,
but then we break
it down per product.
So with 1tap receipts,
the obvious thing here
is the transaction in that term
is a receipt, receipt per user.
Now, the tricky part
here, and the thing
that really threw us off,
was what's more important,
users adding a lot of receipts,
or a lot of uses just adding
a few receipts?
So again, you've got to
think about the value,
and the value is, if
they give us more data,
we can then help
them with their taxes
and do everything for
them, essentially.
So it is all about receipts
per user, and the more receipts
the better.
So then we put it
into our growth model.
As you saw, it's this really
long document of all things--
the whole equation
of the growth model.
So I didn't put all that in
because it's just too much
and it's really boring.
But when we first
wrote that out,
it is about 16 pages
of this document,
and it was just crazy.
So again, we took the idea of
just dumbing it down and making
it something that
anybody can understand.
And the headline here was
Receipts Added Per User,
and it's broken down by
the [INAUDIBLE] divided
by the receipt submissions.
And then it's the receipt
submissions, as you can see,
are defined by the
different entry
points and new and
returning users.
So what was interesting
in here-- as I said,
we're really proud of the
analytics and the tracking
that we put in within the app.
But while we started
working on this,
we suddenly realized, hang on,
we're not tracking this, this,
and this, and these
are all things
that provide value
and make it easier
for us to deliver our
North Star metric.
So suddenly, it made
us realize we've
got to go back and update our
analytics and things like that.
And with this growth model, one
of the most interesting things
it did was that
it made it easier
for us to explain to the CEO--
who I won't bash in
this session today
because he's sat right there.
Hi, Nick.
He's filming as well,
actually, which is even worse.
So it made it so he could see
where the [INAUDIBLE] comes
from, and then the CFO could
see where all the revenue comes
from.
And products, who is
also sitting there,
could see what essentially
would work next to--
what levers to pull to get
the most amount of value.
So then we put it
into this calculator--
this growth model, spreadsheet.
This is just the
first part of it,
but again, you can see here,
with the starting values,
essentially what
happens over 10 days.
And this is just the high level.
It goes further into
detail as you go into it,
but again, that's
boring to show here.
Nobody really wants to see that.
But the best thing
is, it's a predictor.
And this-- and in this
calculator, this spreadsheet--
we actually renamed
it the Calculator.
That's why I keep calling it
that, because to be honest,
nobody really cares about
spreadsheets, especially
myself.
Calculator, because it helps
us predict what we can do.
So actually while
bringing in the equation
from the previous
one-- can we go back?
That one.
So once we had this
equation, and we put it
into the spreadsheet,
we suddenly
started questioning where
the value was as well.
So there was a lot
of things we put
into the original model that
suddenly just made no sense.
So it really gave
us a good lesson
on what we should
be tracking and why,
so it was really useful.
And then the next part is what
the model actually gave us.
So the first thing is, it
gave us clarity about what--
across all departments,
about what it is we're doing.
So the CEO, Nick,
no longer had to ask
about where the
[INAUDIBLE] was coming from
and how we could increase it.
Clear as day in this model.
And then products didn't
have to necessarily ask
what are we going to do next?
What's the priority?
It's all based on this.
And the CFO knew that,
by increasing revenue,
we increased retention, so they
could see from the growth model
as well, essentially,
what is happening next.
Although the CFO does still
sometimes go very Jerry Maguire
and "Show me the
money," but that's--
it's not too bad.
And then the resources--
the big thing we realized is
that, because we're a receipt
app, and we do a
lot with finances,
we should be putting a lot
of priority into accountants.
And that's something
we've not really
done too much of in the past,
so it was a huge wake up call.
That was a huge lever there,
that if we put more effort
into that, we could
essentially get
lots more users a lot easier
and help them keep retained.
Now, that also
helped with hires.
So one of the problems you
have, that we certainly have,
is going trigger
happy on glass door
and just hiring the wrong
people at the wrong time.
So this really
helps with knowing
who you should hire per a kind
of problem you have at the time
and what levers
you want to pull.
So for us, it was
partner channels,
so that was really good.
And that's it.
That's it.
Thank you, Tamzin.
[APPLAUSE]
TAMZIN TAYLOR: Thank you, Jon.
Oh-- wait, I think
mine's working.
Thank you, Jon.
That was fantastic.
Hopefully, that gave you
some really good insights
into, I guess, one model,
one way of working.
Oh, thank you, yes.
What was I going to click with--
my fingers?
One way of working to help
you prioritize and bring
the company together.
Now, one thing you
may have picked up on,
apart from the fact that
there's CEOs in the audience,
was that the model really
helped Jon to communicate
why they were doing certain
things with products,
marketing, CEO, and
all the other teams.
So let me ask you a question.
How many people in
the audience today
do prioritization or
experimentation by them--
just by themselves without
working with anyone else?
A few people.
How many of you
do this in a team?
Just one team?
A lot more.
If you're not doing it
across your company,
you can do better in
a very positive way.
So top developers I've
spoken to ensure that there's
cross-functional
representation when they
do this kind of prioritization
so that everyone's on board
and aligned towards
that common goal,
whether you call it the North
Star metric or anything else
you'd like to choose.
And culture is critical to this.
Need to have an acceptance
of risk and return,
and to take us through
their approach,
more on the riskier
side, I'd like
to invite on stage
Kristina Narusk, head
of product for Memrise.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
KRISTINE NARUSK: Good
afternoon, everyone.
So happy to be here, and I
know that we are running out
of time shortly, and
everyone is quite excited
to get to the longer
networking break.
I think my talk is
going to be brief.
I have to apologize.
I should be doing
this in German.
I'm working in a
language learning gap,
but English is not
my first language.
So maybe this is an
excuse for this time.
Memrise is a favorite
language learning gap
for about 25 million people.
It's very vibrant
and lifelike way
to become confident in
using a foreign language
in any country or any
situation, people experience.
And we have a record number
of over 200 language pairs
that people can learn and
hopefully eventually speak.
And the next few
minutes, I will be
sharing some insights of how
we do product prioritization
and also manage our CEO.
Memrise has had a very
unique journey so far.
So we've been super
lucky with having
one of the most creative and
experimental CEOs out there.
It has its upsides, which means
that it's a great inspiration,
and it injects a lot of creative
thinking and experimentalism
to the rest of the team.
The downside is that it kind
of sets a slightly different
challenge for product
people and product team
to manage the whole thing and
manage all these creative ideas
coming out of the
brains like that.
And as an example,
about two years ago,
I got a text message
from Ed, our CEO,
on Sunday morning, saying
that, good morning, Kristina.
I'm in Scotland.
I bought a double decker bus.
I'm going to find
a repair man who
is going to fix it, a
driver, and a film crew,
and the bus is going to
tour the rest of the Europe
filming videos of native
speakers saying phrases
and sentences in all these
different languages that
are spoken in these
European countries.
So it was quite a
unique experience
to get a message like that.
And what happened was that
we had to come up ways
how to handle these
kind of creative ideas
and very often
slightly crazy ideas,
and how to turn them
into successful features
for our product.
So what happened was we
had to come up with a way
how to filter and how to assess
and measure such crazy ideas
that not just the CEOs, but
also everyone in the team
can come up with.
And we kind of felt
like spreadsheets
and different models
and frameworks
and systems and
processes are maybe
too harsh for filtering
out some genius
pieces of creative glimpses.
And we ended up
having and coming up
with six criteria for how to
filter out useful ideas out
of generic nonsense.
And the six criteria
that we came up with
was every single idea
has to be iterable,
which means that we
should start small.
We should take every
feature as an MVP
and then iterate if
it is successful.
We think that the idea has
to have an immediate impact,
so as soon as we
rollout the feature
and launch it for
our users, we do
want to see some kind
of behavioral change
or some change in metrics.
It has to have a
lasting effect, which
means that one trick ponies
do not quite work for us.
We do want to build features
that have an impact on language
learners for an
extended period of time,
not just for the first five
minutes or the first day.
Everything has to be
measurable, obviously.
And it has to have a power
of localization, which
I think, for a
language learning app,
is maybe a unique but user
base for almost any app in--
out there is very global.
So its good to benefit
from making sure
that it works in
every single language
for every culture for
right to left and left
to right languages.
And finally,
obviously, it all has
to fit into a coherent product,
so even the craziest ideas just
have to fit in somewhere
and make sense.
And we went even deeper.
So in order to keep this kind
of creative and experimental
mindset in the company
and in every single team,
we divided our product
development lifecycle
into three stages, the first
one being the discovery stage
where we prototype.
We sketch.
We design.
We draw.
We user test the idea.
We build something that
we can get random people
from the street to test it out.
In the Memrise Membus
case, the discovery phase
included sending the
bus to a mini trip
to Oxford to film the
videos in English first
to see whether this
makes any sense
or not before touring
the rest of the Europe.
And after doing the dry runs
and testing these ideas out,
we define it in
a fairly detailed
spec with all the
functionality described,
everything, all the sketches,
all the designs drawn out.
We do involve data team in
this stage of the process
quite heavily because
we have to make sure
that we build the feature
for the right user
for the right use case, we
track and implement the data
points in a correct way.
So it's super important
that the data people
are involved in the process.
Once everything is
ready and set up,
the development teams take
over and actually start
building the features.
Because everyone has been
quite nicely involved
in the discovery and in
the definition phase,
it's fairly easy
for the developers
to understand why
we're building things
and how exactly they
need to be built.
From the product perspective, a
super key thing to keep in mind
is that, even with the
most sophisticated systems
and processes in place, it
even happens for the most
experienced product managers
that you sometimes forget
to switch on the
feature and experiment
when it goes out, so that the
users will actually see what
you built. And once
everything is nicely set up,
and the new version
of the app is out,
and now it's time to take
a photo of this as well,
it's the joyful moment
of watching when and how
the results come in.
We are organized as
well, so it's not
like we're all over the
place with crazy ideas.
We have a standard
set of metrics,
standard graphs for every
single experiment, AB test
feature that goes out.
And the day after the release
is like refreshing this page
all the time, which is the
reasonable and sensible way
to see how the feature and
the new idea has performed.
In our team's case, it
shows you the joy and fun
of seeing the results coming in
and learning whether we built
something super successful
that people enjoy
or whether we need to go
back to the whiteboard
and sketch and start
thinking again.
So I think EuroVision is
quite popular in Germany,
so it's almost like
watching the results come--
votes coming in and then
seeing whether we're
on a winning in
case or losing case.
So hopefully, this has
given you a few ideas
how to do product prioritization
without spreadsheets as well,
and also manage the crazy
ideas coming from your CEO.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]